[Musica]
se verrà un giorno in cui non sarà più
conte felicità
sentirò isolato a pelle lara muoversi
andrà bene come va
l'intro di sorriderai felicità la trovi
da entrate
se poi domani pioverà lascia cadere sole
tornerà ti ricorderai dei giorni senza
luce delle notti in bianco o se piangi
sarà invano perché il tempo non ritorno
[Musica]
è meglio vivere ogni giorno so
e sole nascerà per te hai pianto e riso
ok balla insieme a me
nella pioggia quando pioggia c'è e
meglio vivere ogni giorno se il sole
nascerà per te hai pianto e riso ok
balla insieme a me sotto la pioggia
quando c'è pane peso sembra troppo
quando senti che non ce la fate forza
guarda avanti presso tutto questo
passerà all improvviso riderai felicità
la trovi dentro
se poi domani pioverà lascia cadere sole
tornerà è meglio vivere
ogni giorno sai
il sole nascerà aperte di riso
[Musica]
nel gioco doppia già c'è e meglio ogni
giorno sa il sole nascerà per te
ok ma insieme sotto la pioggia quando
[Musica]
sotto la pioggia panda piace
quando piazza c'è
ciao
[Musica]
prima di introdurre la prossima canzone
che racconta di una donna che sta
traslocando ma più che da una casa
all'altra questa donna sta traslocando
da una parte all'altra della propria
vita verso l'indipendenza
vi voglio leggere una piccola parte di
questo romanzo che a che fare con questo
mio nonno aveva una barca si chiamava
libertà e mia nonna per questo non l'ha
mai perdonato andava a pesca il padre di
mio padre amava il mare più di ogni
altra cosa
di mestiere però vendeva corre di porta
a porta e ha sofferto tanto mia nonna
per quella barca a partire dal nome che
portava che non era uguale al suo e che
non era neanche il nome di una santa
capace di proteggere in mare era uno
stupido in nome di fantasia che non
aveva niente a che fare con lei in
nessun modo anche per me e mia sorella è
stato predisposto un corredo sontuoso
ancor prima che venissimo al mondo è
fatto della misura giusta per ridurre i
bivi a un unica strada possibile
io per mia figlia
un corredo non lo farei mai io mia
figlia la chiamerei libertà svuoto i
cassetti di questa casa imperfetta e
penso a quanto sono stata stretta nei
fondi che non
erano i miei chi la salverà erika
sposata che se la porterà a casa chi le
darà alla mano per strada che scalderà
in una stanza gelata che la metterà in
guardia dagli sconosciuti e le aprirà i
barattoli chiusi si deplora da mangiare
killer regalerà un anello natale chi li
inviterà a ballare che parte dal mare
lissa
se la famiglia in famiglia chi l'ha
striglia quanto sbagliati la consiglia
chi ha calmierato con gli incubi di
notte chi reggerà la pronte figlia
sughera legua se la porterà in braccio
per le scale e quando dorme sbatto i
cassetti di questa casa imperfetta e
questo dato sono stata stretto patti che
erano i miei kings moto di cassetti
di questa casa imperfetta
e penso ad otto sono stati dei bandi che
non erano i miei chi la salverà questa
figlia di papà al cinema insieme che
spegnerà la luce dica però sottovoce kg
allaccerà le scarpe quelle presterà
letalità per contare chi segnerà la vita
la porta a spasso nel parco guinzaglio e
bagaglio nina questa bimba china dopo un
po a me ma solo weekend chi le dà aiuto
parole crederà quando grida al lupo al
lupo che cuore grande
per andarmi meglio occhi grandi ai
leggervi dentro bocca grande ai per
mordermi svolto i cassetti di questa
casa imperfetta nei bandi che non
c'erano i miei vuoto i cassetti di
questa casa imperfetta penso a quanto
sono stato eletto nei panni che mani
[Musica]
nessuno
senza nessuno che
dai cassetti di questa casa è imperfetta
e penso a quando sono stata stretta nei
panni che non erano i miei
[Applauso]
[Musica]
nei bandi che non erano i miei